vous qu'est ce que vous faites autour de
la table pour pimenter votre coupe à du
tabasco et sur sa rive ou ludivine par
exemple moi je suis très des petits jeux
dans la chambre à coucher donc neigeuse
érotique
ouais ou bien des choses dans le champ
de connaissances csc on n'avait pas de
uno dans la chanson non mais j'aime ça
mais j'aime les déguisements sur jean
s'est déjà déguisé en cours mais je me
déguise en tellement de choses c'est que
les joueurs on à bercy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi vous attendre à me dire il arrive
vous êtes en abeilles dans l'acsor déjà
laisser décoller vers minutes de galère
il n'est pas du tout fan de négliger
même dit d'arrêter avec mes conneries
j'ai déjà des trucs à faire mieux à
cincinnati chaperon rouge
weiner est cerné j'aime beaucoup ça et
toi fabien tu étais ici on atchoum
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
saleh fait face avec isabelle
morini-bosc ses bras dans sa culotte
ça risquerait de saper des souvenirs
j'aime pas les déguisements mais pour
pimenter ça m'effraie lawrence piro à
vous sauter
laramée pas valoir pour la tâche et je
connais je garde les deux meilleures
pour la fin ça va regarder
j'ai dû regarder la couleur à une
échelle et du poivre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la construction
alors moi je suis célibataire donc c'est
un peu compliqué mais sinon c'est le
côté un peu romantique classique une
jolie bouteille mais où et ça ça fait du
bruit quand ça s'écrase
je viens de comprendre la bouteille
[Rires]
et ses parents
[Musique]
donc toi tu paniques je suis un cadeau
empoisonné
je ne fais rien je suis la pire meuf en
couple j'installe une routine je mange
au lit je ne m'étonne pas du tout c'est
vrai pourquoi lui par contre qu'ils
essayent de me faire des surprises après
j'ai déjà eu droit un petit strip tease
et même là je suis rôle ou en disant
mais regarde moi ça tu vas tout de lui
de partout au sénégal
je partage mes vieilleries non mais mais
c'est au début j achète des
sous-vêtements peu sexy tout ça et après
ces petits bateaux et on met un petit
bateau loin une maquette you back &
noble nungesser c'est alors d'accord et
batterie la la c'est ce côté l'addition
long terme a relevé le niveau
ce matin c'est cesser mon choix n'est
mission
[Musique]
tim et des bouteilles sur les questions
bêta pour pimenter ton coupe alors moi
depuis que je sais que on peut se
déguiser en l'abeille est peut-être
tenté le gros bourdon
on va faire son petit effet elle s'y
attend pas et cyril vous faites quoi
vous
[Applaudissements]
voilà on voit d'abord par les cas c'est
les deux j'ai laissé pour la fin
d'accord si ces quatre meneurs d'hommes
alors on va terminer par car parce que
c'est celle qui intéresse assez bas
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça et je vais
vous dire ce tour de table car tu
t'expliques est vraiment savoir les
autres on a demandé aux chroniqueurs et
surtout en attaque
qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient pour mettre
un petit peu plus de piment et on est et
on allait finir ce tour de table avec
les deux que vous attendez
magloire et clara morgane ses deux
soutiens différentes mais les envoient
beaucoup mitton deux salles deux
ambiances des m'apparaît gloire oui
alors majorque l on fait bien évidemment
moi jamais surprise j'ai mes trucs
impossibles à faire d'emprunt kinder et
les déguisements des déguisements d'en
arrêter demain vise en abeille parce que
vous êtes excusés en abeille accroché à
un harnais blague d'enfance qui n'est
pas une blague
un jour en face des lises avril lit à
baldaquin j'ai voulu faire c'est de vous
les faire sauter
j'ai voulu ténébreuse gasconne qui s'en
sert réussi et mon partenaire et moi
même avons coulé y artères à un étage
plus bas
voilà c'est tout le juge parent a dit
c'est assez rare dont voilà voilà
allez on a fait cette séquence oui car à
fait nous rêver non mais oui et c'est
que j'ai des détenus de cabaret chez moi
là partout il ya des strass et de la
dentelle mon mari c'est aussi mon
photographe ont fait des photos
érotiques
ensemble tout autour c'est bientôt son
retour fin août ensemble et ya des
petits objets est ce qu'on peut dire que
là ça va
[Applaudissements]
les autres et on devrait alors en
premier ici un pipeau c'est le modèle
enfant n'a pas bien tu sais quoi c'est
son nom de famille j'explique parce que
j'ai ouvert une boutique on arrête pas
là deux joueurs qui est des dieux dédié
à l'amour donc elle la longeraie il ya
des bougies de massage et des souhaits
jouent alors déboucher les bougies
d'anniversaire et alors peut-être une
bougie en fait qui se transforme en
mille de massage et foule à verser
directement sur vous et c'est vraiment
très adroit et la dernière fois donc je
vais dans ma boutique
j'ai récupéré les produits dédiée à
l'amour encore une fois avant de venir
chez vous et ensuite je prenais l'avion
et je me suis rendu compte que je
pouvais pas les amener dans l'avion vous
savez et je les ai donnés à tiffany en
lui nommant vers le garder ça secret
voilà merci je vais chez moi il ne sert
à rien de mettre avec ou avec quoi qu'il
fallait non c'est un petit lubrifiants
moi là bas j'étais là pour raconter des
blagues